Now back to our initial question.
What does all of this mean for Alice, Bob, and Carol?
We have already seen that
the problems they are trying to solve are contained in NP
and so what we could now try is
to show that their problems are actually
NP complete.
To do that, what we need to do is
we need to reduce SAT
to one of their problems,
and we're going to do this with clique.
It's also possible to do this with vertex cover or independent set,
but clique is actually one of the easier ones to see.
And now what we need to show is
for any given instance of SAT,
so for any Boolean formula, if you will,
we can transform it
into an input for the clique problem
in polynomial time such that clique
as a decision problem will say yes
if the Boolean formula has a satisfying assignment
and no otherwise,
and once we achieve this, we know that clique is NP complete
and since we have already seen there are polynomial time reductions
between clique, vertex, and independent set,
if clique is NP complete,
then these 2 problems here are also NP complete
which of course will mean that
not only will Bob be very unhappy about this,
but Alice and Carol will be in this together, as well.